咁我今日嘅聚会呢有个名嘅,
个名叫你的罪赦了,
可能你觉得你咁唐突嘅呢,
第一次见面,
为何会讲你的罪赦免呢,
咁旁边有幅画嘅,
旁边有幅相,
咁其实嗰幅相呢,
系从呢本书嗰度嚟嘅,
咁我唔知你见唔见到我手上,
依家揸住呢本书啦,
咁呢本书咁,
我諗就唔系好多人睇一明,
因为呢佢用尼泊尔文写成嘅,
咁我就喺呢个加德满都买嘅,
咁就,
这里是主耶稣在地上的一件事
稍后我们会有机会讲一下
刚才当你听完Killy
听完细辉说
不知道你羡慕他们人生的改变
我就想起圣经这一句话
它说什么呢
唯有那个以力量束我们腰
使我们行为完全的
它是神
今日我们认识这位神,他不是一道道理,
他是活生生的一位
有人说近朱者赤,近物者黑
你发觉信神的人,他人生都有改变,有经
历
都会变好,从这里你可以看见,不单是神
是真,并且他是很好的
他是用力量束我们的腰,使我们行为完
全的那一位
我都盼望你今日因着认识这位神
你人生都有这样的改变
在我的枱头有一个摆设
经常提醒我神是很真实的
你见不见到我手上握着这件事
可能就黑一点
其实这个是一个磁浮的地球仪
咁我有时都买嘢送畀自己
咁就呢个地球仪提醒我啲咩嘢呢
咁喺以前呢好多人呢以为地球系平嘅
所以到今日呢都有一个学会叫做国际地平
学会
就话地球系平嘅咁样
咁所以以前嗰啲人讲呢
行船跑马三分险
点解呀
点解行船咁危险呀
因为他觉得地球是平的
如果走得远
他就会跌下去
好像一个瀑布中了下去
所以以前那些人航海
就会贴着在岸边走的
走一阵又远岸
下一阵又远岸
不敢远洋航行的
因为他怕跌下去瀑布
你发觉
人什么时候才知道
原来地球是圆的呢
其实去到这个
你见到呢度有两幅相啦
咁就去到呢个希腊时代呢
去到呢个公元前二三百年呢
咁有啲人都想㗎喇都諗㗎喇
就系咩
啊
睇见月食慨时候呢
月球有个阴影喎
即系太
地球遮住咗太阳嘛
有个阴影投射有啲弧度喎
啊
所以都猜想地球系有弧度㗎
比如有亦都有人留意到呢
就系
喺同一日里面呢
就喺唔同慨地方呢
发觉太阳照射的影是有不同的
在埃及的地方,影是垂直的
但是过了几百里之后
影就有一个角度
猜想到地球是有弧度的
但是到什么时候才证明到地球是圆的呢?
其实是去到中世纪,去到16世纪
所以为什么哥伦布、默哲伦那些这么出名
呢?
因为他们的发现是冒着生命危险的
因为如果远洋行行,地球如果真的好像方
的话,他们就一去回不了头了。